hallo liebe leute wir sind heute zurück
in münster mit einem neuen thema für
euch und dieses thema ist ein witziges
thema es geht nämlich um macken macken
sind etwas jahres ist das dass es so
quasi komische eigenarten die menschen
haben die vielleicht ein bisschen
merkwürdig sind und das versuchen wir
heute zu erfahren was die leute so viele
macken haben los geht's
wir haben jetzt christoph getroffen wird
er uns noch mal hast du ne macke ja ich
habe eine große markt gefertigt aber du
meinst er so was was was was man macht
was man für mich ganz normal hält
nämlich an das sprachlich erklären dem
makel kann auch sein dass jemand ein
bisschen blind bleiben ist oder
bescheuert
ich hab' ich habe in der tat so eine
kleine macke genau und zwar trage ich
permanent einen glückscent mit mir in
der hose herum also den ich von dem ich
glaube dass er mehr glück bringt und
wenn ich dann kein glück
das wird er ausgetauscht das habe ich
eine macke ich sage immer das wort
abgefahren abgefahren abgefahren ist
auch eine macke wer bestimmte worte ganz
offen bin abgefahren habe ich eine macke
hat
wer nicht ja und was hast du für eine
anordnung nach das manchmal auch andere
leute sicherung der hinsicht bin ich
recht konsequent wusste auch sachen von
anderen ordnen
leider insbesondere energie dafür schon
mal gemacht hast du von anderen das
irgendwie wir sachen aufgeräumt hast und
dann sauer war
ich behaupte dann immer ich räume auf
und die behaupten immer ich versteckt
die sachen haben sie eine macke ich lese
gerne spielt sport ob es eine obsession
ist weiß ich nicht
nein ich glaube nicht das ist eine macke
müssen oder immer zu spät kommen dass
nicht die 90 bin ich ein post
ich weiß ich habe die marke lässig immer
irgendwas suche meine brüder mein handy
mein schlüssel aber ich glaube das ist
eher vergesslichkeit ja haben sie eine
macke bin schrecklich ungeduldig finde
ich schon macht sich das bemerkbar
ja dass ich den leuten der nerve sie
sollen voran machen oder dass ich immer
viel zu früh irgendwo ankommen
vor lauter panik dass ich zu spät kommen
oder was sind dann so die nervigsten
macken die debatten an menschen
feststellen
also zum beispiel bei messen permanent
die facebook timeline zu checken
das mit macke das ist eine große macke
die leider sehr sehr weit verbreitet
sondern ich total nervig finde
deswegen haben wir zum beispiel die
vereinbarung dass wir beim essen dass
das smartphone oder was auch immer uns
gerade begleitet in die mitte legen
und wer als erster das nimmt der darf
den tisch abräumt
tatsächlich gerade darüber geredet dass
wir alle so ein bisschen vielleicht und
macke angewöhnt haben von dem jeweils
anderen übernehmen und zwar sache ich
jetzt seid ihr denn was in ordnung geht
wenn ich etwas zu etwas zu stimmen
er hat die marke er muss alles ordnen
aber das ist ja keine macke sondern auch
kommt ja auch mir zugute
ich bin jetzt echt noch überlege ich
hoffe wir hatten großen speicher stick
auf jeden fall eine positive meistens ja
haben sie eine macke bestimmt natürlich
habe ich bin sonst erzählen kann ich
sagen ja aber da nicht meine ecken und
kanten haben weiß ich ja nur jetzt auf
anhieb eine konkrete zusagen liegt mir
nicht
was darüber aufregt kann sich nicht zu
hören keine macke also geld jetzt kein
ein ihr kennt mich doch was ist meine
marke
drückt etwas zurück
ich tanze verrückt hast du ne macke
bestimmt ja bestimmt also ja ich glaube
ich glaube ich hab sogar ein oder zwei
marken könnte man sagen
kennst du dir ja also eine macke ist ich
bin halt sehr ungeduldig also dass da
hab ich auch schon her dass die kann ich
schon beschreiben es gibt bestimmt auch
macken an mich selbst offensichtlich gar
nicht bisher gesehen habe vielleicht
meine partnerin wesentlich besser
wahrnimmt als ich selber gehört
definitiv dazu
auf jeden fall schon mal ein fakt
es fällt keine macke 1 das soll keine
arroganz seine feld einfachen von meinen
zahlreichen marken die ich bestimmt habe
gerade keine ein däne ein von ihm jetzt
ich könnte noch von mir einer sagen ich
mache oft erst auf den letzten drücker
so jetzt ich bin auf den letzten drücker
hier erfolgsmarke ja ich hab bestimmt
mehrere marken aber mir fällt ein dass
ich immer noch mal wenn ich das haus
verlasse gucke ob die türen
abgeschlossen sind zum beispiel die
meisten der rechnung so die marke habe
ich auch die habe ich noch meinen vater
übrigens glaube ich angeeignet bekommen
der macht das auch mal so da gibt's ja
auch leute die machen das ganz extrem
manchmal gehe ich auch zurück war ich
mir nicht sicher bin habe ich so den
herd ausgemacht überflüssig weil man
hatte den herd vielleicht gar nicht aber
wahrscheinlich hat man sich das wirklich
abgeguckt von den eltern mutter vater
oder so glaub ich auch ne andere frage
aber ist ja noch lang ist glaube ich ein
anderes also das ist schon heftig so
heftig ist es bei mir nicht
es war kein zwang eine marke hast du
eine macke eine macke ich bin manchmal
sehr perfektionistisch
ja und das steht mir auch manchmal im
weg wie macht sich das bemerkbar dass
ich ja bei allen möglichen aufgaben auch
wenn es eigentlich schon gutes immer
noch weiter das verbessern möchte merkst
du damit andere leute
ich denke definitiv schon ja
ja klar wie eine marke wie jeder ich bin
sehr sehr unordentlich und organisiert
schon ordentlich das ist manchmal etwas
zwingen brauche ich für viele sachen
länger weil ich dann immer noch erst mal
suchen muss und merkst du andere leute
damit meistens mich selbst aber manchmal
auch andrea habt ihr auch macken mit
denen die andere nervt
ich hoffe nicht kommt immer
grundsätzlich sehr spielstark dem muss
man immer sehr lange warten dass eine
unangenehme macke einer von euch hier
hast du ne macke
ja ich komme notorisch zu spät notorisch
und nervt das andere ja schon mal stress
mit freunden
meistens kann man es ganz gut abschätzen
schon es ist natürlich alle bescheid ist
familiär bedingt nicht ändern wollen
ich kann es nicht ändern aber ich gebe
mir mühe ich versuche ja liebe leute das
war's für diese woche mit der episode
zum thema machen
jetzt interessiert uns natürlich von
euch habt ihr auch eine macke die leute
hier in münster waren heute unglaublich
ehrlich hat mich überrascht jetzt von
euch wissen was enorm an
zum schluss verrate ich noch meine macke
ich habe immer ich muss immer alles
kontrollieren bevor ich das haus
verlasse auch manchmal so dass ich denke
noch mal zurück grafisch hat das auto
wirklich abgeschlossen hast du die
haustür aufgeschlossen
das ist eine solche macken ich weiß das
aber ich kann es nicht abstellen
jetzt will ich wissen dass ihr macht
danke fürs zuschauen und unterstützen
uns weiterhin vor allem bei kathrin sind
wir sehr sehr dankbar für jeden
supporter hier unten findet ihr den link
es gibt auch viele extras dort für euch
wenn ihr euch unter uns unterstützen
möchte bekommt ihr auch viel von uns zum
beispiel extra footage was wir aus der
episode raus geschnitten haben danke
fürs zuschauen und wir hoffen wir sehen
uns nächste woche wieder
ja lieber jetzt habe ich gerade groß
erzählt dass ich ja die marke hätte dass
ich immer alles kontrollieren würde
unter anderem kontrolliert immer noch
mal ob alles abgeschlossen ist habe ich
auf den ball gerade selber nicht gemacht
jetzt nicht panisch mein schlüssel
gesucht und dann bin ich zum par zurück
gelaufen weil ich dachte vielleicht habe
ich den fahrrad den schlüssel im vaart
stecken lassen und habe dort diesen
netten zettel gefunden gefundener
schlüsselbund weiß im café flot da hat
tatsächlich jemand offenbar habe ich den
schlüssel hier irgendwo liegen lassen am
fahrrad und bin weggegangen und ein ganz
nett am end hat diesen schlüssel
gefunden und im café abgegeben
jetzt habe ich ihn nieder danke dir wer
auch immer du bist mein schlüssel